it came to pass in those days  the Caesar Augustus issued a decree that  there should be a census of the entire  Roman world so Joseph also went up from  Galilee out of the city of Nazareth to  the City of David that is called  Bethlehem because he was of the house of  David  and there were Shepherds dodging in the  nearby fields and keeping watch over  their flock by night and lo a messenger  of the Lord appeared to them and the  glory of the Lord shone around them and  they were greatly afraid the messenger  said to them fear not this will be  assigned to you you will find a baby  wrapped in cloths and lying in a manger  suddenly a great company of the heavenly  host appeared with the angel praising  God and saying glory to God in the  highest heaven and on earth peace to  those on whom his favor rests from all  of us at Hillsdale College to all of you  and your families Merry Christmas  [Music]